foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar spatial
insights from Clinical biopsies why
lymphocyte relationships matter
I am Kaylee walk of labyrts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by altaview to learn more please visit
ultaview.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
gorab Chatterjee PhD associate director
research and development and associate
director product strategy and management
at altaview Incorporated so Rob you may
now begin your presentation
thanks Katie
thanks for joining us
um overall
I would like to focus a little bit more
on
what happens within clinical biopsies
how can we get it better uh towards the
next generation of clinical biopsies and
towards uh in in that context why does
lymphocyte relationships matter
so before we move there let's uh I'll
just talk briefly about what what
altitude does and what is a debut so in
that adult review
uh our our mission is
to develop products and services using
spatial phonomics that utilize the
emerging knowledge of human biology and
enable the data-driven development of
personalized cancer Therapies
um so uh we'll talk a little bit more
about the spatial phenomics aspect the
term that we coined and also how does
data-driven development of uh
personalized cancer therapies can lead
us to a better solution overall our
vision is to give every patient the best
chance of a cure by revealing the true
state of cancer
uh brief fast facts about LT view uh we
were founded in 2015 by David Walt and
Pung Yin from the Harvard West Institute
of biologically inspired engineering
our platform technology The Institute
Plex or ISP which I'll be referring
through the likes of the talk is a novel
DNA barcode based Multiplex
immunofluorescence uh technology
that uses DNA barcodes attached to
antibodies and
also with the signal amplification that
we need uh
can you okay so I think this is a good
zero
so a barcode DNA barcode attached to
antibodies and uh along with uh
supported with the signal amplification
mechanism that provides higher contrast
as well as better quality images for
Multiplex immunofluorescence settings on
ffp tissues we provide a direct antibody
detection technology that enables a very
rapid Planet development
and higher resolution
because you are detecting the antibodies
directly compared to using a secondary
antibody based approach
we are optimized we have optimized our
reagents on formally fixed and paraffin
uh embedded ffp tissues uh that are
usually by that are used routinely in an
anatomic pathology workflows and labs
and is a standard for clinical pathology
right now we are a Food Service Company
uh including manufacturing operations as
well as clear certified Services lab as
well as a detailed image analysis
Pipeline and Associated team with it
over the last uh seven years we have
focused on
um uh getting four rounds of
um funding including uh above
like including uh over 100 million
dollars and we have extensive experience
with over 100 antibody targets
across 100 uh more than 100 novel
Multiplex panels that spans across
hundreds of projects and multiple
companies mainly working on uh in the
biotech sector including farmers and uh
like small farmers and big farmers our
Focus right now so far has been on
immune oncology and we are supporting
biopharma research biomarker development
and clinical development Pipelines
so let's talk a little bit more about
the current state of uh the immuncology
drug development
the main one of the main things to
consider is uh towards towards getting
uh getting getting uh good progress in
the in the field of Immunology drug
development is the checkpoint inhibition
which the concept has remodeled Cancer
Care and it's called currently
complementing surgery radiation and
cytotoxic chemotherapy as well as
molecular targeted therapies towards
Precision medicine
and moreover immunotherapy has improved
outcomes in several of the most
refractory solid tumors such as
melanomas lymphomas and a set of other
wide variety of cancers but uh so so
towards that end we when we come towards
lymphocytes we want to understand why
are lymphocytes important
so lymphocytes are the main underlying
mechanism behind what we generally
routinely call in the clinical workflows
as is it a cold tumor or an intermediate
tumor or a hot tumor
um it's mainly dependent upon how much
your body's own immune response is
interacting as well as acting on the
tumor and it can range
across a wide range of variation
depending upon the presence or absence
of different immune cells as well as
um uh corresponding associate or
Associated immune responses but towards
that end abundancies identities and the
location of these lymphocytes and also
other cells in the tumor
microenvironment matter is hugely
towards defining uh the tumor
classifications as well as your body's
own response to a particular tumor
the field of uh clinical Diagnostics or
the field of clinical pathology has been
uh improving but on a quite low slow
pace the the complexities that we are
seeing uh have been exponentially
increasing over the recent years but it
all started with
um uh the h e the classic h e staining
the hematoxylin and ears in staining
that was uh about like more than 50
years ago uh that h e staining mainly
focused on the morphology and the
morphology determines the diagnosis of a
particular slide that you look into and
this is still currently the gold
standard among Pathologists uh towards
making a diagnosis on a clinical biopsy
samples but towards more personalized
medicine the complexity of the human
microenvironment
is is is important and it's driving the
need for Multiplex biomarker detection
on a same tissue sample so the field
improved from there from the h e uh
phase towards an even histochemistry
phase where you can detect particular
proteins now you are not only dependent
upon morphology you can detect
expression of particular proteins but it
is mainly has been limited towards
single protein detection although there
have been improvements there but also
the cell identity and the cell State and
uh the the predictive biomarkers like
her2 and pdl1
these have all been uh we we have been
able to detect these but at a single
protein detection level uh and towards
driving it towards more personalized
medicine then the multiplex
immunofluorescence assays and
Technologies came up more recently the
advantages with them being you can
detect multiple proteins or multiple
biomarkers
um on a single issue section together
that enables a deeper cellular
phenotyping based on uh over expression
of one or more biomarkers on the same
single uh on a single tissue section
this also provides us with a wider
expression range of expression because
um immune histochemistry technology
being a catalytic reaction overall it's
very prone to make the markers or that
the signals saturated so and it's harder
to get a differential expression between
different cells
on the same tissue section based on
their copy numbers
so Multiplex similar fluorescence
technology is actually advantageous in
that range in that sense
and by detecting different biomarkers
more than one biomarker on a single
section you can further dig like you can
dig deeper into uh analyzing the
intercellular interactions as well as
the cellular networks between uh that
that forms on a particular tissue
section
a brief overview of something that came
up more recently and it's becoming more
and more practice in the clinical uh as
well as translational research space uh
tertiary invite structures the the
lymphoid Aggregates and the tertiary
part structures have been shown to
predict outcomes of pdl1 blockade in
this one study that we were a part of uh
in uh on non-small Cell lung cancer
um so uh
this overall detects this overall shows
us that complementary Technologies like
RNA seek as well as multiplexing the
fluorescence Technologies like ISP can
be used together to make a better
decision on strategizing
um uh the the diagnosis as well as
classifying different uh cells or
different patients
towards getting a better so that each of
them get get a better treatment
um so in in that sense it's it's a
significant progress and significant
step forward towards uh using
combination therapy towards making a
better outcome or having a better
diagnosis
some case studies about why lymphocyte
location matters so this in this
particular study that uh uh we were a
part of along with Rovers uh we will
looking at
a therapy where uh cd-137 Agonist has
been uh uh were added or like was
subjected to uh action that promotes the
proliferation of CDA T lymphocytes and
that was administered to cancer patients
and then we are looking at tumor
biopsies stained with kr67 as well as
cd8
and this is uh also done with DAV uh the
traditional immunohistochemistry
staining as well as ISP staining but the
main focus was
um uh to classify the the cancer
patients based on like responding to the
drug or not responding to the drug but
what was found was the responded
population had increased cd8 cells
intermingle with the tumor cells uh so
they were in close proximity while the
non-responders had seen the increased
cd8 positive cells uh separated from the
tumor cells so the T cells are not
infiltrating that much to the tumor
areas
similarly if you look into another
example
um we uh we can take a look at uh this
study RTX 250
um which was subject administered to the
cancer patients that expands the T and
the encase uh lymphocytes and the tumor
biopsies after subjected being subjected
to ISP staining and image analysis we
will be able to we were able to find out
that the Baseline biopsy samples had the
T cells not touching the tumor samples
so the approximity analysis can show us
whether cd8 positive T cell is is
actually very very close to a tumor cell
or not but what we found out that uh on
on treatment biopsy samples the T cells
will be much more proximity to the tumor
cells so these are good indications
about how we can dig deeper into
cellular interactions of particularly
different cell types on tissue sample
and get better diagnosis of a particular
treatment that's working or not working
let's talk a little bit more about the
technology platform so that I can give
you a better idea about how it works
so we have been focusing mainly on SFP
tissue samples
um our technology is a platform
technology that is primarily dependent
upon detecting multiple biomarkers up to
8 or 12 or even 16 biomarkers on a
single dish section
with a fast and simple workflow so we
start with a slight preparation that
requires an anti-retrieval and dewaxing
the the panels are pre-optimized and
they are species independent
so and then we proceed towards after
after anti-retrieval and de-vacing we
proceed towards an antibody binding step
which is literally adding all the
antibodies that you want to use for
detecting a particular panel it can be
four it can be eight or twelve
you add all the antibodies together as a
single antibody binding step each of the
antibodies have a unique DNA barcodes
attached to it which are used for
detecting that particular antibody so as
I mentioned before that we are detecting
the primary antibody directly that leads
to a higher resolution and that also
leads to
uh us leads us to be able to detect more
than more than three or four antibodies
together because now we are not
um limited towards host specific
interactions and optimizing that but
just the orthogonality of DNA sequences
Define the the uh
absence of of a crosstalk between
different antibodies
we don't mask the antigens because we
are directly detecting the antigens
through primary antibody and we don't
use any harsh techniques or harsh
protocols that may affect the morphology
as well as Integrity of tissue samples
after the antibody staining happens we
move forward towards amplifying the DNA
barcodes or extending the DNA barcodes
using our proprietary signal
amplification method
that increases the sensitivity of the
the signal that we detect and also you
can that that leads us towards detecting
more having a more differential outlook
on the whole tissue sample so that we
can detect
lower expressing cells as well as higher
expressing cells as well as medium
expressing cells on the same tissue
section with equal efficiency
and then after amplification we add our
fluorescent probe mixes which are
reverse complement sequences of our DNA
and barcodes but with the fluorophobe
dye attached to it and that's how we
detect different antibodies with a set
of four antibodies at each round and
that's primarily because we are limited
by the spectral
overlap between the different
fluorophores or dyes that we currently
are using in the translational research
space so we can detect up to four
antibodies at one round but this can be
followed up with a very gentle signal
removal step
and we can come up with like fresh set
of probe mixes which are four other DNA
strands attached with the same four set
of little dies and image it in round two
and overlay the image is there by
getting an H Flex or 12 Flex images
So based on this technology
we offered pre-optimized view signature
panels that can readily address your
specific biological questions and that
when we say panels these are the
combination of different antibodies that
you're using uh to address your specific
biological question we have our fixed
view kits which are pre-optimized with
our off-the-shelf markers which are
ready to ship the kits are ready to ship
and you get
um either a four Plex or an apex fixed
view uh kit within a couple of weeks if
at all if there is any delay because of
supply chain or any other issues we also
have a Flex View eight Flex kit where we
can start off with the base panel of an
aplex panel which is mentioned here as
the fixed view aplex panel but we have
the option of swapping any two markers
or up to two markers
with the market of your choice from the
set of pre-optimized off-the-shelf
markers that we have
each of these markers have been
extensively
studied as well as developed in in ulti
view so that we offered the best
pre-optimized uh condition for maximum
or most the most optimal staining
performance
and those are available uh we can ship
them uh by four weeks we also offer a
uview panel which is the custom made to
order panels of up to eight Plex where
you can choose any of the eight markers
from our set of uh pre-developed markers
and we can
create that custom panel and and work
with you and and ship them to you uh
within six to eight weeks and each of
these markers have been pre-optimized in
terms of the conditions so that they
don't have any interaction with each
other as well as they perform to their
fullest uh efficiency which can be
determined by uh oneplex signal or
OnePlus assay and we have seen that
whether you are detecting a particular
marker in one Plex or an eight Plex
format this thing the staining
performance is very similar
so let's talk a little bit more about
the the signature panels that we have so
it's mainly towards uh the understanding
of you want to explore the scientific uh
uh state of a tumor micro environment or
a specific biological questions we start
off with this base immunoh panel that
includes CD3 CD4 cd8 and cd68 as in
round one as well as Fox P3 pd1 pdl1 and
cytocheritine soxtin Cocktails for uh
tonsil and other tissue types like
melanoma where it's oxidant comes into
picture
and apart from this base panel we have
optimized 13 additional markers which
are available for the swap in as I was
mentioning before
so let's look into what can we achieve
by swapping in particular markets for
example you can get a macrophage eight
Plex panel by swapping in
CD 163 and cd11b
from the 13 optimized marker list to the
base immuno8 panel similarly you can get
an immune reactivity panel by focusing
kr67 and Grandson B where you are for
where you are mainly interested in the
the reactive immune response of a
particular tissue
if you want to focus on tertiary
nymphoid structures we can swap in cd20
and cd11c markers that focus on that
that Target more of the tertiary part
structures
as well as you can have tumor inflating
lymphocyte panel that are focusing on NK
cells as well as other infantig
lymphocytes by swapping in ca20 and cd56
so these are different examples these
are just food I gave you four examples
but like these are there are the the
possibilities is unlimited uh based on
your specific question or your specific
previous experience with a particular
set of markers and we can work with you
to get the most optimal panel that can
answer your specific biological question
towards like so for for getting a little
bit more understanding about how our
technology works and getting a little
bit more confidence on that we have
extensively studied our technology as
well as our essay to have a very robust
spatial biology uh biology biomarker
detection uh platform
with very good Multiplex immunofluences
assay performance so and we have tested
it across in a particular study uh
including 330 different samples and our
sensitivity of ISP was uh around 98 and
specificity for pdl1 was around 92
percent
so that goes hand in hand with the com
the the current gold standard of
um of the technologies that we use in
the clinical and translational research
uh but also because of the advantage of
being detect uh you're you being able to
detect multiple proteins or multiple
biomarkers together in a single
religious side
you can diagnose challenging cases that
require a deeper understanding of what's
happening with the tissue micro
environment
towards the assay performance sustaining
performance we have compared our assay
towards the current gold standard which
is dab and our staining of ISP staining
and dab IC staining are very highly
concordant whether you are doing a
multiplex uh ISP or even a monoplex ISP
and our technology is highly
reproducible across a wide range of
markers
for across multiple different runs
whether you're a single run or in
multiple independent runs and we have
seen that we see very highly consistent
uh readings across cell densities which
are positive for particular markers as
well as signal intensities but for
particular cases we also see slightly
higher variability of unique markers
with unique markers like cd68 macrophage
markers and upon further investigation
we can see that we have starting to see
or detect the inherent biological
variability of particular markers across
different serious sections of tissues
and across different regions of tissue
microenvironment so we we can even dig
deeper into the the inherent biological
variability of particular markers using
ISP
let's talk a little bit more about the
spatial phenomics and what what can we
achieve with spatial phenomics current
uh which which can lead us to progress
towards having a better uh clinical
um workflow
towards personalized medicine
so Multiplex data in combination of the
with the classic pathologist annotations
can really show you the power of spatial
phenomics and just how many types of
questions can be answered
when what I mean by that is you can have
a multiplex immunofluorescence image but
also pathology is uh being highly
familiar with the h e stain we can even
overlay a multiplex immunofluorescence
image with the hne stain of the exact
same particular Slide by doing a
sequential staining and overlaying uh
the two images together we can then
utilize this incredible and detailed
Multiplex analysis along with the
pathologist annotations to further
improve and train possibly next
Generation AI algorithms but also have
manual analysis uh supported by
Pathologists but with more information
given to them about the current state of
tissue micro environment
with an h e sample our it it is this
being a gold standard for Pathologists
right now towards technology like
detecting what happens with the tissue
one reason is uh by looking at uh in in
looking at h e samples is asymmetry
particularly in cancerous tissues and H
E focuses more on the recurrent
morphological patterns with that that
has a biological significance based on
the extensive straining that
Pathologists do and uh the the
understanding that they have by looking
at numerous images over their uh career
but
overall Pathologists also understand
that although they look very similar
there are based on their experiences
they can detect stroma from a tumor uh
environments as well as uh tumor
inflating lymphocytes which are these
small deep blue uh dots that you see in
the hne state but essentially all
lymphocytes look alike in it on h e so
for example if you take a look at this h
e staining
although the three cells which are
marked uh by arrows yellow arrows they
are all lymphocytes but how can we know
better or how can we have a deeper
understanding of what kind of
lymphocytes are they that's where
Multiplex immunofluorescence techniques
come into uh pictures where we can
detect multiple one or more protein
biomarkers
for each of these cells and overlay that
with the h e staining and have a better
understanding whether it's an exhausted
T Cell based on whether it's CD3
positive as well as pdn1 pd1 positive or
it's a non-exhausted T Cell which is
just CD3 positive so you can make that
distinction between the T cells but also
on NK cells which are like cd56 positive
but CD3 negative
so those distinctions and a much deeper
understanding of uh the tissue
microenvironment can be achieved using
Multiplex immunofluorescence in
conjunction with h e images and then we
can go back to our h e image and then
have a better understanding of the
tissue micro environment
this h e tissue stain can be hyper
annotated with the ISP multi-marker
phenotypes and moreover our insiduplex
assay our four-plex NC duplex assay
takes five and a half to six hours and
you can have a fully automated assay run
on uh Auto standards like Bond directs
uh you can run 30 slides together
and because of our unique signal
amplification technology you can even
use auto scanners where you can image up
to hundreds of slides using um auto
scanners like size axio scan and because
there is a single amplification
technology or a step present the
exposure times are super low thereby
having much lower uh scanning time for
particular slides even with the even if
you are doing a whole slide scan
so the spatial phenomics using uh
powered by ISP particularly enables this
precise cell phenotypes a whole slide
quantitation and spatial analysis you
can have a correlation with the tissue
morphology backed up by the h e stain
and you can further dig deeper into the
cellular phenotypes towards particular
biomarker discovery
and moreover on top of that you can also
have training of artificial intelligence
and deep learning networks to improve
the interpretation of the hnes slides so
that in the future you can have just h e
slides to get a basic understanding
before you dig deeper into
multipleximino fluorescence using
multiplexing references with those
slides
so for example we can what I mean by
that is we can start with the classic h
e stain for pathologist annotations to
determine the tumor regions
however when we accompany that with the
multiplexing fluorescent images we can
dig a little bit deeper here
we can start with a simple dappy nuclear
counter-strain image showing all the
cells in the region and add the tumor
regions like tumor regions in in Red by
staining cyticality or by detecting
cytokeleton there
this is of course performing the whole
slide scale and we have the overlay
showing in the the analyzed cellular
localizations of and the cellular
phenotypes that are um there in this
white circle region on but on the on the
left so you can see the tumor regions
and the non-human uh the tumor cells in
the non-tumor cells in that particular
area
but then we can also detect T cells
which are strained here in green which
are CD3 positive cells and you can see
that some of the T cells have
infiltrated into the tumored regions
as seen in this white circle
but some also have remained in the
non-tumor compartments which are the two
green clusters flanking the white circle
now
with an additional marker let's say a
CDH we can differentiate these T cells
populations a bit further into cytotoxic
T cells which are in light blue
to get a better understanding of the
overall nature of the T cells or the
state of the T cells that we have right
now
and then we can pair that with the
macrophage stain which is like let's say
cd68 and we can show that these immune
cell clusters have been very much primed
by antigen presenting cells and are
within the tumor regions and so they are
positioned to attack the tumor cells
readily and then we can come up with
another pdl1 stain
to see like as it's shown here in yellow
and we can see these tumor cells have
responded by expressing pdl1 which is
like which can be classified as more
immune invading tumor cells
and this patient might be a good
candidate for anti-pdl1 therapies so
this is kind of like one example of
diagnosis that you can do
these stand along with the proper
analysis can give you a much better
understanding of what is occurring
within the tumor micro environment
and also we can actually see how these
cellular interactions are happening in
the tissue so we just highlighted five
markers here to answer one particular
question but this tissue was actually
run with 12 biomarkers and which can
provide even more data and clearer
picture about the tumor microenvironment
and exactly what's happening within the
tissue so you can have a better
understanding for like let's say drug
Discovery or patient treatment for
example
how does a supporting image analysis
pipeline help
so again we can see here are just some
examples of what we can do with all this
data we can do a whole slide
quantification
and we can quickly run
holes like quantification based on each
of these markers and we can start
further strategize the the tumor cells
the T cells the cited toxic T cells and
the macrophages and the bulk scale like
how what's the percentage of tumor cells
what's the percentage of T cells Etc
but we can then generate a more detailed
phenotypic analysis for all the cell
types present based on expression of one
or more of the particular markers
like for example T helper cells or
macrophages or immunosuppressive
macrophages based on ct68 pdl1 double
positive cells
and we can then break the tissue into
different compartments the tumor versus
non-tumor as as we you can see here
we can then use this defined tumor and
non-tumor cell regions to look at the
cell population within these regions
this highlights a very important
function which is the importance of
location data for example information
about the immune cells infiltrating the
tumor borders can also help determine
whether a tumor is classified as like
hot or cold and indicates its potential
for Target Therapies however we just
don't have to stick to just tumor versus
non-tumor we can even segment it into
more detailed regions for example if it
is it a immune invading tumor an
invitory inhibitory macrophages or even
is it a stromal tertiary lymphed
structure
or just different cell clusters as you
can see in the in green
and you can have detailed analysis for
each of these regions by
compartmentalizing based on the
um the the the pre-work that you do for
the image analysis
we can even look at the cell clustering
throughout that issue so for example
here are two different regions of the of
the tissue with similar very similar
cell numbers but however in the region
on the right if you see the T cells can
spread out and generate more cell to
cell interaction because they are very
much dispersed dispersed across the
region of Interest so they can have more
active immune response with multiple T
cell tumor cell interactions but on the
on the left our analysis showed that the
T cells are much more clustered towards
the left of the towards the left of the
region of Interest so maybe there is
some local inhibition uh that's uh of
the Prime T cells that's preventing any
further dissemination of the Diesels
into the tumor micro environment
thank you
so for these reasons spatial data is key
and determining exactly what's occurring
to the issue so furthermore proximity
analysis can provide insights on how
active the immune response is in this
tissue for example the regulatory T
cells as shown here in break and
regulate the T cells shown in green as
long as they're in the same vicinity
and the tissue of the T Cell which is
not proximal to this region they might
be activated and inhibited uh and they
are free to roam and kill tumor cells so
all these analysis can tell you a lot
more about the tissue
we then are able to summarize all these
details uh about the cellular
phenotyping a deeper understanding of
what's happening in the tissue and with
expert analysis in a report and then
help you get to your specific answer
so our current image analysis package
has these um features that we talked
about like multiple marker phenotyping
of up to eight significant or relevant
phenotypes for four Plex 16 for up to
eight Plex and further segmented by
tumor versus non-tumor regions of the
tissue
and we include a special phenomics
report which includes cell
quantification cell densities marker
intensities as well as segmentation of
different regions on the tissue
so overall these things can as I
mentioned before that these things can
help you understand the biological
question as well as the state of the
tissue or the tumor micro environment
that you're working on
so in summary analysis of the legional
tissue biopsies
maybe the the only or the primary way to
determine why a therapy works or does
not work and we can strategize next
steps accordingly and the multiplexer
analysis of these biopsies will be fully
required to comprehend all this the
different cell phenotypes and the
interactions that drive these lesions
and our technology is uniquely poised
towards fulfilling the the vision of
this spatial phenomics because we can
allow or we allow rapid creation and
deployment of these panels using a very
simple workflow that is integrated into
the major uh or the standard pathology
Labs right now we don't require a
specific instrument we don't require a
particular
um technique to operate
and furthermore we can definitively
identify different cellular phenotypes
using
um the h e tissue context and provide
like supporting data to the pathologist
to make a better decision
overall I think it would be good to have
to bring the spatial phenomics
Technologies to diagnosis diagnostic use
but that would require a very diverse
collaborative
environment and agreement on the
biologically based or intervention
related outputs and that is something
that we are just scratching the surface
in terms of more
targeted and personalized molecular
medicine
so with that I would want to thank you
and I would
um happily answer any questions that you
have
great well thank you gorab for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started we've got a few in the
queue here so our first question asks
what are the advantages of ISP compared
to existing mif Technologies
that's a that's a good question so the
one of the advantages of ISP as I was
briefly mentioning during the talk is we
are able to directly detect the antigen
sites using uh primary antibodies so in
that sense we can detect up we have been
able to detect up to four
biomarkers on a single cell with high
level resolution so that you can further
quantify
uh or for the localized the presence of
these particular biomarkers whether
they're in the cytoplasm or nucleus or
membrane using a standard 20x uh
fluorescent microscope also
furthermore our ISP technology is based
on very gentle handling of the tissues
that we work on so it allows for further
Downstream processing of this particular
tissue if needed so we can facilitate
combination Technologies using the same
ratio so for example h e or even even
further downstreet processes like
sequencing that are becoming
increasingly popular in terms of uh
translation and clinical research
so these are just couple of advantages
that we can think of
thank you another question we have here
is there a limit to the amount of Cycles
allowable
so fundamentally there is no limit
towards the number of cycles that are
allowable
um as I mentioned like we can only
detect up to four antibodies in one one
round because of the optical limits of
the current microscopes that we have and
the dyes that we can get with minimal
crosstalk but we have tested uh
internally in in our research settings
we have tested up to four rounds
uh thereby detecting up to 16 antibodies
but we have not seen any particular
interference or any particular effect
like effect of a particular staining of
a particular marker whether it's in
round four or round one
and that is highly because our signal
removal and then reprobing process is
very gentle and we don't use any harsh
chemicals toward to to remove the signal
and we can even go further like more
than that more than four four rounds
it's just we have been focusing on
um
amid to low to mid Plex but like faster
and high throughput assays that can
answer questions and answer specific
biological problems uh that the
translational research in the
pre-clinical research Market needs
great thank you another question we have
here how much time does it take to run
an aplex assay
yeah so a fourplex essay I was
mentioning uh is takes about five and a
half hours including anti and retrieval
and uh the devaxing
um but after that the single ampl the
signal removal and reprobing is about
one hour one one and a half hours so
it's not linearly the asset time does
not linearly increase with the number of
plexes or the number of rounds that you
have to do
so overall an apex assay would be more
like an eight can be done within eight
hours but of course you have to take
into consideration the Imaging time that
you take between round one and round two
but assay time wise it's it can be done
within eight hours
eight
next question here asks how do you
ensure minimal interference while
detecting multiple biomarkers
yeah so our
dealing with the crosstalk or the the
interference between different
biomarkers is mainly Guided by the DNA
barcodes and we have done extensive
research internally to ensure that each
of the DNA barcodes that we have
um uh attached to their different
antibodies they are very very orthogonal
to each other so that they don't have
any
for even partial interactions uh which
are significant in the time frame and
the temperature that we are working on
in the in our assay so that's how we
ensure that there has been very minimal
interference between the multiple
biomarkers that we have in terms of the
detection side but from the staining
side because we have primary antibodies
uh only and no secondary antibody which
have more of an interaction or a
crosstalk we are safe in that sense that
we will be able to have the interference
we will be able to have minimal
interference as long as we choose the
particular right antibodies that have
been screened and validated to have very
high specificity for a particular
anti-insight
wait
we're going to go ahead and wrap up
there today go rob do you have any final
comments for our audience
thank you thanks a lot for joining uh
please let me know if you have any more
questions uh my email ID is uh here in
the slide and I'll be happy to uh
communicate or have a conversation with
any of you later on
great well thank you again gorab for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Alta View for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye